l'union européenne déterminé à imposer
un nouveau train de sanctions à la
russie parmi les propositions faites par
les commissaires européens l'embargo
total sur le pétrole russe d'ici six à
huit mois l'exclusion de banques russes
de la plateforme swift mais aussi
l'interdiction de trois médias publics
russes des ondes européenne nous
adressons ainsi un autre signal fort à
tous ceux qui mènent la guerre du
kremlin nous savons qui vous êtes et
vous devrez rendre compte de vos actes
l'union européenne veut interdire à ses
états membres l'achat de pétrole russe
transportés par mer et par oléoduc car
depuis l'invasion de l'ukraine l'europe
a versé quelques 20 milliards d'euros à
la russie cela reste un défi pour les
états membres qui vont devoir trouver de
nouveaux fournisseurs la hongrie et la
slovaquie jugée trop dépendante de
l'énergie russe pourront continuer leurs
achats avec la russie jusqu'en 2023 nous
allons arrêter les achats de pétrole
brut d'ici six mois et les produira
finale d'ici la fin de l'année
nous exerçons ainsi une pression
maximale sur la russie tout en réduisant
au minimum les dommages collatéraux pour
nous et nos partenaires car pour aider
l'ukraine nous devons nous assurer que
notre économie reste forte
ce sixième paquet de sanctions
européennes frappant notamment une
banque russe importante la sberbank mais
aussi cinquante huit personnalités dont
le chef de l'église orthodoxe russe
soutien affiché de la guerre contre
l'ukraine la famille de dimitri peskov
porte-parole du kremlin et de nombreux
militaires soupçonnés de crimes de
guerre abou de chat les 27 états membres
doivent encore approuver la proposition
pour que les sanctions entre en vigueur